donc nous poursuivons aujourd'hui les
travaux de notre commission d'enquête
sur la pénurie de médicaments et les
choix de l'industrie pharmaceutique
française par l'audition de Madame
Christelle ratini carbonet directrice
vous êtes directrice générale de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé et
je vous remercie Madame la Directrice de
vous êtes mobilisé dans un très bref
délai donc je suis Laurence haribail
vice-présidente de la Commission et
j'excuse notre présidente qui a eu un
une difficulté pour pouvoir être avec
nous aujourd'hui mais en tant que
vice-présidente je suis ravie de
présider cette séance sous la houlette
de notre rapporteur Laurence Cohen placé
sous la tutelle du ministère de la Santé
la NSM est notamment chargée d'évaluer
les bénéfices et risques associés aux
produits de santé tout au long de leur
cycle de vie de l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché qu'elle délivre à la
surveillance continue des effets
désirables des médicaments
l'agence procède pour cela à l'analyse
des signalements qu'elle reçoit ou
directement à des inspections chez les
opérateurs impliqués dans la fabrication
l'importation ou la distribution des
produits de santé l'agence participe
aussi et vous pourrez nous en dire un
mot au procédures d'autorisation d'accès
précoce ou d'accès compassionnels
permettant à des patients d'accéder à
des produits de santé qui ne disposent
pas encore de notorisation de mise sur
le marché ou qui disposent d'une
autorisation pour une autre indication
enfin et surtout vous êtes chargé de
veiller à la disponibilité des
médicaments indispensables et c'est le
noeud de notre questionnement puisque
nous travaillons sur la pénurie de
médicaments
et c'est pourquoi nous avons souhaité
vous entendre Madame la Directrice
générale un stade précoce de nos travaux
puisque il s'agit d'un deuxième audition
de notre commission d'enquête pour
remettre un peu en contexte alors que le
nombre de ruptures ou risque de rupture
déclaré à l'agence augmente très
fortement ces dernières années nous
souhaiterions que vous dressiez un
bref présentation introductive un
panorama de la situation actuelle avec
la question Quels sont les principaux
médicaments touchés quels sont les
risques sanitaires associés à ces
problèmes d'approvisionnement et
l'agence
ditpose-t-elle de moyens nécessaires
pour y faire face je passerai ensuite
avec après votre propos liminaire la
parole à notre rapporteur Laurence Cohen
et puis et puis ensuite nous aurons des
questions de nos collègues membres de la
commission je vous précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et fera bien
entendu l'objet d'un compte-rendu publ
ié et avant de vous passer la parole
Madame la Directrice je vous rappelle
que nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
commission d'enquête et que un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 433 13 434
434 15 du code pénal et je vous invite à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure
éventuellement si d'autres vont
intervenir vous pouvez prêter serment ou
a priori vous intervenez seul
très bien donc je vous remercie et je
vous passe la parole
sur ce propos liminaire
merci merci beaucoup madame la
vice-présidente madame la rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames et messieurs je tiens
évidemment à remercier la commission
d'enquête pour donner l'opportunité à
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé que
j'ai l'honneur de diriger de pouvoir
vous présenter en effet au travers des
quelques propos liminaires le rôle et
l'état de la situation sur le sujet de
la couverture des besoins de nos
concitoyens en produits de santé et
particulièrement en médicament et puis
évidemment dans le cadre des échanges et
des questions que l'ensemble des membres
de la commission pourront pourront poser
en effet à l'agence quelques éléments en
effet introductifs et vous m'indiquerez
lorsque vous souhaiterez que j'aborde le
sujet des accès dérogatoires précoces
compassionnels et cadres de prescription
compassionnel mais peut-être
centrons-nous en effet évidemment sur
sur l'objectif de cette audition donc
sur les tensions et éruptures et
ruptures en vraiment la situation en
effet est une situation et tout le monde
en effet on a bien conscience est une
situation qui est complexe avec un
nombre de tension et de rupture qui
augmente de manière importante j'y
reviendrai j'y reviendrai en effet un
petit peu plus tard sur le sujet
évidemment des médicaments également
aussi sur les dispositifs médicaux mais
nous allons nous entrer en effet sur sur
les médicaments et c'est un sujet de
préoccupation qui est évidemment
constante pour pour l'Agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament et des
produits et des produits de santé
quelques mots très rapides sur la
situation nationale versus la situation
européenne ou internationale c'est une
des situations de tension et de pénurie
et nous avons à disposition quelques
quelques
je l'ai en anglais désolé quelques
diapositives merci j'avais slide en tête
quelques diapositives en effet qui
permettent d'illustrer la situation ou
les situations de tension et et de
pénurie importante et je pense par
exemple sur les dernières les dernières
semaines et les dernières mois
amoxicilline et paracétamol c'était une
situation qui est vécue par l'ensemble
des États membres de l'Union européenne
mais également au niveau au niveau
international donc nous sommes face en
effet à une augmentation des
déclarations en effet de signalement de
risques de rupture de rupture ou de
risque de tension ou de tension qui est
en effet extrêmement extrêmement
important sur les dernières années où
nous sommes en effet à un petit peu plus
de 3500 signalements de déclaration de
tension et de rupture sur l'année
notamment 2022 quand j'indique
déclaration cela ne veut pas dire que
nous avons 3500 médicaments en rupture
ou médicament en tension et on est on y
reviendra très probablement évidemment
dans le cadre de nos échanges tout
l'encadrement législatif et que vous
avez évidemment que vous avez évidemment
porté et réglementaire
oblige les industriel a déclaré le plus
tôt possible des risques potentiels de
tension ou de rupture toujours dans la
même philosophie pour nous donner du
temps à tout ce collectivement aussi
bien l'agence mais avant tout les
patients et les professionnels de santé
pour nous donner le temps nécessaire
pour mettre en place des mesures de
réduction du risque pour tenter de
limiter au maximum les impacts délétères
de ces situations de tension et de
pénurie sur sur les médicaments
évidemment c'est un toutes les actions
en effet que nous mobilisons sont
orientés vers un but
ultime à savoir à moindre rire les
conséquences pour les patients pour les
professionnels de santé aussi pour
l'organisation des soins puisque cela
désorganise évidemment les soins il y a
évidemment des risques possibles de de
perte de chance des impacts délétères et
donc l'objectif en effet est de pouvoir
réduire au maximum ses impacts ces
impacts extrêmement importants
également aussi je souhaiterais je
souhaiterais rappeler dans ces dans ces
propos dans ces propos liminaires
l'importance en effet de de bien
distinguer les deux dimensions dans la
situation de la couverture des besoins
sanitaires des patients sur le
territoire national avec la notion de
gestion des tensions des ruptures
lorsque celles-ci sont déclarés et c'est
évidemment la mission pleine et entière
de l'agence qui ne travaillent pas seul
on ne travaille jamais seul on travaille
avec les patients on travaille avec les
professionnels de santé au quotidien
pour essayer en effet comme je le disais
d'amoindrir les conséquences les
conséquences délétères on a également et
grâce à vous notamment au Sénat on a
également aussi un dispositif qui se met
en place sur les dispositifs médicaux et
grâce à votre mobilisation dans le
projet de loi d'adultes en effet et avec
l'introduction en effet d'un amendement
pour encadrer aussi réglementairement
les tensions les déclarations des
tensions sur sur les dispositifs
médicaux
je rappelle également que la
l'approvisionnement du territoire
national en médicament et de la première
responsabilité des industriels qui sont
titulaires des autorisations de mise sur
le marché de ces médicaments et dont
évidemment la première responsabilité
est de pouvoir couvrir les besoins des
patients en effet et lorsqu'ils mettent
en effet sur le marché une spécialité il
y a une population cible qui est définie
il y a une indication en effet qui est
définie et l'objectif est bien qu'il y
ait des approvisionnements qui soient à
hauteur de de ses besoins qui sont
estimés et identifiés bien évidemment il
peut y avoir des aléas et on y reviendra
probablement dans les dans les questions
des aléas de production des aléas
évidemment de fabrication et puis des
consommations largement augmentées et on
le voit typiquement sur paracétamol et
amoxicilline et si vous en êtes d'accord
on pourra passer un tout petit temps en
effet sur sur ce sujet là et je peux en
effet il y en a suffisamment je pense un
pour l'ensemble assez déjà circulé
désolé et on pourra en effet y revenir
des augmentations de la demande qui sont
extrêmement fortes on l'a eu avec les
médicaments de réanimation notamment
pendant la première phase la première
vague pardon covid mais également on l'a
vu là sur amoxicilline n'est pas
rascétamol et donc il faut ensemble
évidemment et aussi avec les industriels
trouver des solutions et puis il y a une
deuxième dimension qui est
l'anticipation puisque l'objectif
évidemment pleine et entier en tout cas
pour enfin pour nous toutes et tous et
pour la directrice générale que je suis
c'est de ne pas avoir à gérer des
tensions et des pénuries et d'avoir en
effet des mécanismes d'anticipation pour
essayer de prévenir au maximum c'est
c'est ces situations en effet de tension
on va le voir en effet après sur le
sujet des plans en termes d'épidémie
hivernale mais également de manière plus
large et là évidemment c'est un sujet
très interministériel inter
institutionnel seul la NSM voilà ne peut
ne pas évidemment pas gérer et répondre
à l'ensemble à l'ensemble des questions
et des interrogations mais pour autant
il y a cette nécessité en effet
d'anticipation et reparlera je pense
identification des vulnérabilités
relocalisation aussi en effet un certain
nombre de questions qui ont déjà été
posées et auxquelles nous vous
transmettrons évidemment des réponses
écrites avant la date mentionnée je
crois du 3 mars si je ne dis pas de
bêtises donc vous aurez évidemment
l'ensemble des éléments voilà on
pourrait probablement parler des heures
en effet sur le sujet mais j'ai bien
conscience que nous avons nous avons en
effet 1h30 si vous êtes peut-être si
vous en êtes d'accord madame la
vice-présidente et Madame la reportage
juste quelques éléments sur les
diapositives en effet qui ont circulé
que vous avez que vous avez en effet
sous les yeux sur la situation en effet
particulière paracétamol et amoxicilline
qui illustre un certain nombre en effet
de de segments et d'éléments en effet
assez assez représentatif dans le cadre
des situations de tension vous le sur
paracétamol en effet un grand nombre en
effet de de pays donc de l'Union
européenne sont concernées par la
situation au niveau du paracétamol vous
le voyez aussi également sur sur
l'amoxicilline évidemment avec des voilà
et de ce fait avec une situation
européenne assez
assez homogène sur la situation de
détention de ces deux produits mais
également aussi hors Union européenne on
a des échanges réguliers avec avec mes
homologues américains la FDA ou
également au Canada et donc la situation
est assez analogue ce que l'on voit à la
fois paracétamol et amoxicilline nous
avons fait face où nous faisons encore
face à une situation particulière de
triple épidémie comme vous le savez
grippe covid et VRS donc bronchiolite
avec une acuité très importante sur la
fin de l'année 2022 enfin l'automne 2022
et début 2023 et notamment pour le virus
donc pour le VRS pour la bronchiolite
une précocité importante donc avec en
effet un nombre de cas extrêmement
important et avec un impact également
sur l'organisation des soins donc sur le
paracétamol c'est un peu différent de
l'amoxicilline une demande en effet à la
fois pour la partie adulte pour les la
population adulte mais aussi pédiatrique
extrêmement importantes eu égard aussi à
la rémanence en effet de cas de covid on
le sait on a eu également la 9e vague
les cas sont de moins en moins sévères
grâce à la vaccination et c'est une très
bonne chose pour autant il y a toujours
des cas de covid qui nécessitent de
l'antalgie et qui nécessite en effet qui
nécessite en effet aussi des traitements
antipyrétique et donc une augmentation
de la consommation importante de
paracétamol à la fois sur la partie
adulte mais également aussi sur la
partie la partie pédiatrique donc de ce
fait une augmentation des besoins
importants une mobilisation aussi des
industriels puisque les
usines tournent 7 jours sur 7 et 24
heures sur 24 mais pour autant la
demande très forte au niveau
international voilà montre en effet les
difficultés de pouvoir de pouvoir
répondre à la demande dans des temps
dans des temps très courts à titre
d'exemple sur le paracétamol et la
partie pédiatrique la formulation
pédiatrique car la suspension buvable
sur des cendres 2021 il y avait à peu
près 1,9 millions de flacons qui ont été
dispensés sur la solution pédiatrique en
décembre 2022 nous étions à un petit peu
plus un petit peu plus de 3 millions de
suspension de flacons de suspension
buvables donc on voit bien une demande
qui a été particulièrement augmentée sur
l'amoxicilline vous le voyez également
aussi une augmentation donc pays
européens voilà largement concernés et
une situation un peu différente puisque
2020 et 2021 vous avez il y a eu à la
faveur des confinements et des mesures
barrières une diminution très forte de
la consommation d'amoxicilline et en
2022 une reprise des épidémies
hivernales des pathologies hivernales ce
qui a évidemment augmenté la de manière
très importante et le délai de remise je
dirais en marche de manière plein et
entière des lignes des lignes de
production voilà appris un peu de temps
il y a eu ce délai pour revenir en effet
à
une capacité de couverture des besoins
en amoxicilline également et je ne
prendrai pas plus de temps vous avez les
documents sous les yeux nous avons aussi
une situation spécifique au niveau
national par rapport à la consommation
en termes de médicaments nous sommes on
le sait les la France est très grosse
consommatrice de médicaments vous le
voyez notamment sur l'amoxicilline ou et
on le sait on a un usage assez enfin
très important en effet des
antibiotiques vous avez la comparaison
avec plusieurs États européens donc avec
l'Allemagne Italie l'Espagne et le
Royaume-Uni et où vous voyez en effet
donc c'est des données qui sont
mobilisées qui sont mobilisés en effet
donc au travers d'aikuvia et donc avec
une consommation une utilisation
d'antibiotiques particulièrement
importante au-delà de la moyenne enfin
des autres européens sur le paracétamol
vous le voyez également aussi nous
sommes bien au-delà de nos homologues
européens avec un point à moduler
notamment sur les données pour l'Espagne
et l'Allemagne en Espagne en Allemagne
le traitement de première intention de
l'antalgie et antipyrétique n'est pas le
paracétamol mais l'ibuprofène dans les
recommandations donc de ce fait c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes au-dessus mais quand on regarde
les données sur l'ibuprofène nous sommes
en deçà évidemment de l'Allemagne et de
l'Espagne pour autant lorsque l'on fait
l'addition des deux on voit qu'on a
quand même une consommation qui est qui
est au-delà donc on a un sujet
évidemment de bon usage qui nous rend et
le fait que nous sommes très gros
consommateurs cela nous rend d'autant
plus sensible aux tensions et aux
ruptures en effet eu égard au volume
très très important que voilà que nous
utilisons et que nous consommons et
ensuite mais je ne détaillerai pas pour
ne pas prendre trop de trop de temps
vous avez la présentation de toutes les
mesures qui ont été mobilisées dans le
cas du paracétamol et de l'amoxicill à
la fois en termes d'interdiction
d'exportation puisque grâce à la
réglementation la législation qui existe
lorsqu'un produit est déclaré en tension
donc par l'agence avec une mise en ligne
d'une fiche de rupture de stock sur
notre signe site pardon cela coupe les
exportations par les grossistes
répartiteurs ce qui veut donc dire qu'il
y a interdiction d'exporter et que tous
les stocks qui existent notamment chez
les grossistes reste sur le territoire
national pour couvrir les besoins des
patients des patients en effet sur le
territoire national et évidemment des
recommandations que nous que nous
érigions avec les professionnels de
santé avec les patients à la fois sur le
bon usage mais à la fois aussi sur
l'ensemble des mesures qui peuvent être
mobilisées des préparations magistrales
aussi pour aider à couvrir les besoins
mais je ne rentre pas dans les détails
sur ces éléments et vous avez un effet
l'ensemble de ces éléments et puis
évidemment une information qui est qui
est constante avec nos parties prenantes
les patients les professionnels de santé
au travers évidemment de réunions de
travail au travers de réunions
d'informations que nous avons voilà que
nous mobilisons en effet de manière je
ne sais jamais si c'est bien
hebdomadaire ou bimensuel enfin tous les
15 jours je crois que je crois qu'on
peut dire les deux d'ailleurs beabi
hebdomadaire en effet pour partager les
infos recueillir aussi les informations
du terrain des échanges très très
réguliers quasiment voilà
quotidiennement avec avec les
pharmaciens notamment les pharmaciens
d'officine qui sont en premier au
premier en contact avec le patient et
pour trouver des solutions évidemment
les médecins et les associations de
patients et derniers éléments dernier
élément pardon la dimension européenne
qui est indispensable on le reverra
évidemment
ultérieurement vous le savez il y a des
travaux en cours sur la révision la
législation pharmaceutique au niveau
européen avec normalement un objectif
d'entrée en vigueur plutôt en 2024 ou
2025 donc le les premiers travaux sont
en cours le premier le projet devrait
intervenir devrait être publié fin mars
donc donc rapidement et sur le sujet des
pénuries la situation spécifique de la
France sur l'encadrement réglement
législatif qui existent et réglementaire
et notamment depuis 2016 et qui a évolué
au cours du temps
et est un exemple qui est regardé
évidemment par la Commission européenne
et et j'appelle de mes vœux et on croit
savoir on n'a pas encore le projet de
texte clair mais que l'ensemble de la
réglementation en effet notamment qui
existe au niveau national sera repris en
base dans le projet soumis à
consultation par la commission la
Commission européenne sur les plans de
gestion des pénuries sur voilà les
déclarations les obligations en effet de
déclaration donc très clairement le
système qui existe aujourd'hui n'est pas
suffisant on le voit bien puisque c'est
un amortisseur notamment avec les sujets
des stocks de sécurité c'est un
amortisseur mais cela n'annule pas le
risque c'est un amortisseur mais voilà
donc il faut encore aller en effet
évidemment probablement plus loin pour
et c'est évidemment objectifs de votre
de votre commission de votre commission
d'enquête pour répondre en effet à la
fois aussi à ces situations que l'on a
de tension et essayer d'anticiper au
maximum ces situations à la fois
notamment par rapport aux médicaments
aux médicaments critiques et puis sur
certaines populations où on sait que la
population pédiatrique est
particulièrement sensible en effet à ces
situations de tension et de et de
rupture l'offre étant beaucoup moins
importante que pour les populations
adultes et je m'arrêterai là pour mes
propos liminaires merci beaucoup c'est
infiniment si je me permets simplement
dire que on avait produit un avis
politique dans le cadre de la commission
des affaires européennes et qu'on a reçu
la la réponse de la Commission
européenne qui confirme ce que ce que
vous dites par rapport à ce qu'on
préconisait mais ça résout pas le
problème la preuve vos diapos vos slides
le prouve je vais passer la parole à
notre rapporteur pour une série de
première question et puis ensuite on
engagera le la réflexion avec les
collègues
oui merci beaucoup Madame la Directrice
pour votre propos liminaire donc moi
j'ai été membre du conseil
d'administration en tant que sénatrice
donc de l'Agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament de 2012 à 2020 donc c'est
une c'est une agence que je connais un
petit peu voilà
et j'ai toujours été extrêmement
vigilante et pour faire en sorte que cet
agence à qui on donne de plus en plus de
missions puissent avoir les moyens
humains et financiers correspondant aux
missions qu'on leur donnait
malheureusement je n'ai pas été très
entendu me semble-t-il de ce point de
vue là et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
donner plus de missions à une agence si
on ne fait pas on ne prend pas garde
justement au moyen pour les mettre en
œuvre ça je voulais déjà faire cette
cette remarque là
vous avez reçu donc un questionnaire
comme l'a dit la présidente de 25
questions donc je ne doute pas que vous
allez y répondre avec avec beaucoup de
d'application et nous aurons tous les
détails possibles moi je voudrais
insister sur 400 points pour laisser la
place aussi aux questions à mes
collègues c'est vrai que la pénurie ce
n'est pas un phénomène récent la pénurie
des médicaments puisque il y a eu
d'ailleurs différents rapports qui ont
été faits au niveau parlementaire que ce
soit au niveau du Sénat ou de
l'Assemblée l'Assemblée nationale mais
par exemple si on regarde en 2016 il y
avait à peu près 600 signalement et
aujourd'hui on en est à plus de 2000
2400 vous avez dit là en 2021 3000 3500
donc on voit que les que les
signalements ont été multipliés par au
moins un 5 en une année en un court
moment et donc c'est pas lié du tout
seulement à la crise de la de la covid
puisque je crois qu'en 2019 on
ressentait 1500 signalements et c'est
ces pénuries quand même ou ces ruptures
de stock touchent des produits qui sont
extrêmement divers sont par exemple des
anticancéreux ils
rétroviraux ou même certains produits à
base d'insuline et d'ailleurs ça fait
défaut dans dans les traitements dans
les traitements des patients donc ma
question ma première question justement
c'est de devoir avec vous si il y a en
fait
un point particulier concernant les
médicaments anciens qui sont moins moins
onéreux et donc moins rentable pour les
exploitants et de ce fait là est-ce
qu'il serait moins touché que les autres
quel est votre analyse et est-ce qu'il
existe des difficultés
autre ou sembla par rapport aux
médicaments
on dit innovant ça c'est ma ma première
ma première série de questions par
ailleurs donc vous avez vous avez
effectivement des dispositifs qui sont
mis à votre disposition je sais que vous
avez été alerté en amont par rapport à
la pénurie d'amoxicilline et aussi de
doliprane comment est-ce que vous avez
pu traiter donc
c'est c'est ces questions de pénurie
parce que on a on a eu le sentiment que
ce soit en tant que parlementaire ou que
ce soit en tant que simple usager que
quand même il a fallu beaucoup de temps
pour avoir des mesures qui essayent de
de pallier c'est ces pénuries donc
qu'est-ce que vous avez pu ou pas pu
mettre en place c'est ma deuxième série
de questions et je sais que vous avez la
possibilité notamment d'infliger des
pénalités financières mais j'aimerais
bien savoir combien de sanctions vous
avez pu vous avez pu infliger parce que
dans les dans les éléments que j'ai il y
en a extrêmement peu je crois que ça
doit concerner en
2020 de signalement peut-être
très très peu et en tout cas il y a une
grande opacité sur le montant des
pénalités financières donc là vous êtes
devant une commission d'enquête vous
avez prêté serment donc on aimerait en
tant que parlementaire avoir des
éléments beaucoup plus tangibles sur ce
que vous pouvez faire quels sont vos
moyens d'action parce que c'est
effectivement un moyen un moyen d'action
vous voyez j'ai je regarde mes mon
papier 2020 une sanction pour rupture de
stock contre deux en 2019 voilà quels
sont les chiffres donc si vous pouvez
nous en dire nous en dire plus ça serait
un élément important pour notre pour
notre enquête
ma troisième question c'est que le
ministre a demandé d'établir une liste
de tous les médicaments essentiels pour
juin 2023
puisque effectivement il y a la
nécessité de
réagir face à ces pénuries mais cette
liste de mon point de vue existe déjà
c'est celle notamment de l'OMS et
j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre
analyse sur comment finalement vont
s'articuler ces deux listes ce qu'elles
vont rentrer en contradiction est-ce que
c'est pas finalement redondant et est-ce
que c'est si pertinent que ça de
réitérer une liste alors qu'on en
dispose de la part d'un organisme comme
comme l'OMS et enfin ma dernière ma
dernière question ça concerne les
solutions qui qui pour vous permettrait
de réduire les risques de pénurie alors
elles peuvent être multiples elles sont
à la fois dans des décisions politiques
en matière effectivement de santé mais
elles sont aussi vous l'avez un peu
abordé en au niveau industriel donc on
est nombreux et nombreux à penser que il
faudrait
relocaliser un certain nombre
d'industries pour pouvoir avoir une
production effectivement en France alors
toujours en lien et en collaboration
avec le niveau européen mais on sait
pertinemment que les les la plupart des
usines se trouvent en Chine ou en Inde
d'abord pour des raisons de rentabilité
financière contenu du coût de la main
d'oeuvre etc mais également pour des
raisons environnementales parce que ce
sont des des
usines qui sont assez polluantes donc
est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez
vous par rapport à cette à cette
relocalisation est-ce que ça vous
permettrait également y compris d'avoir
peut-être plus de de latitude par
rapport à ce qu'on vous demande en
termes de sécurité de suivi etc des
produits est-ce que ça serait pour vous
une facilitation en plus de l'apport que
ça pourrait donner effectivement
aux besoins des Français et des Français
en matière effectivement de médicaments
voilà il y en aurait beaucoup d'autres
mais il faut laisser la place à chacun
et chacune parce que c'est le jeu pour
moi d'une commission d'enquête c'est que
chacun se sentent vraiment partie
prenante de cette commission et puis se
poser toutes les questions
qu'ils portent merci
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteur je
vais essayer d'être le plus
concise et le plus clair possible pour
laisser évidemment la place aux autres
questions sur votre première question
donc en effet une hausse des
signalements des déclarations à peu près
par 5 entre 2016 et 2021 un point un
point important à souligner comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure les
évolutions législatives récurrentes et
notamment notamment à partir de 2019
avec la LFS 2020 qui ont demandé et qui
ont en effet requis de la part des
industriels des déclarations le plus tôt
possible des risques possibles de
tension et de rupture est un élément
dans l'augmentation aussi du nombre de
déclarations de signalement il y a aussi
plus de médicaments qui sont en tension
et en rupture mais l'augmentation en
effet de la déclaration et est en lien
direct en effet avec le dispositif
législatif et réglementaire demandant en
effet plus une déclaration le plus tôt
possible pour autant on voit on a vu
aussi également et notamment à partir de
mi-2021 et début 2022 une augmentation
du nombre de déclarations avec prise de
mesure c'est à dire que lorsqu'il y a
une déclaration et qu'il y a une prise
de mesure derrière c'est qu'on a bien
des médicaments qui sont en effet en
tension et où en rupture avec la
nécessité soit d'un peu des mesures à
prendre soit d'importation soit de
contingentement par exemple et on était
plutôt aux alentours de de 25% à peu
près sur l'année 2021 on voit que sur
2022 on est plutôt à 40% de signalements
qui nécessitent la prise de mesure donc
on a ces deux éléments plus de
déclarations parce que on demande à à ce
que les déclarations soient le plus tôt
possible mais également aussi en
parallèle un nombre plus important de
déclaration avec la nécessité de prise
de mesure
sur votre question concernant
quel type de médicaments sont touchés en
effet entre les médicaments anciens ou
dit ou que l'on appelle mature et les
médicaments innovants la très grande
majorité des tensions
concernent des médicaments d'immatures
et il n'y a très peu de cas de tension
de pénurie sur des médicaments dit
innovants on est plutôt dans ce cas là
lorsqu'un nouveau médicament arrive on
va dire une progression dans la mise à
disposition qui peut être un petit peu
plus longue ou égard à la technicité à
la fabrication et donc par rapport aux
demandes qui arrivent en effet c'est il
peut y avoir un petit décalage dans le
temps mais sur des réelsions ou à
pénurie on est très très majoritairement
sur des médicaments d'immatures vous
avez pris l'exemple des anticancéreux
les tensions que l'on peut avoir ou les
pénuries sont sur des médicaments en
effet mature dit de première intention
on envoie peu voire très très peu sur
les médicaments
dit innovants
sur le la deuxième question concernant
les mesures en effet paracétamol par
exemple vous aviez indiqué paracétamol
et amoxicilline et vous l'avez sur sur
l'une des slides de la slide de 6 sur le
paracétamol les signes en effet de
d'augmentation de la consommation et
donc de difficultés possibles de pouvoir
garantir la couverture des besoins avec
la production a été des la fin du
premier semestre de 2022 avec des
mesures qui ont déjà été prises des
juillet 2022 en effet
avec la recommandation de distribution
fractionnée notamment par les
pharmaciens d'officine des
recommandations aussi en lien avec les
syndicats de pharmaciens d'officine pour
appeler à la responsabilité de chacun et
qu'il n'y ait pas forcément d'achat
parce que vous savez le paracétamol est
à la fois sur prescription mais sans
prescription pas d'achat d'un nombre de
boîtes trop important en effet notamment
en prescription médicale facultative et
donc au fur et à mesure et vous le voyez
là avec des mesures qui ont pu être
mises en place depuis juillet 2022 pour
essayer de faire face à la situation en
effet de la demande qui est qui est en
effet important sur la moxicilline
également aussi et notamment au travers
de la précocité des pathologies
hivernales et des infections aussi
respiratoires aiguë donc au début de
l'automne donc dès octobre ou avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes nous
avons en effet mobilisés des mesures
qui ne qui clairement en effet ne
résolvent pas tout et on le voit bien et
vous l'avez et Madame la vice-présidente
vous l'avez indiqué mais qui essaye en
effet de limiter le plus possible les
impacts le sujet on va revenir sur les
sanctions financières le sujet parce que
je pense au stock le sujet concernant
les stocks de sécurité vous le savez en
effet depuis 2020
septembre 2020 merci septembre 2021 donc
la mise en place de stock de sécurité
pour les médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur on a à peu près
6000 amittm sur les 12000 médicaments
qui sont dans la pharmacopée la
pharmacopée française nous avons donc
deux mois de stock de sécurité pour les
MITM qui peuvent être donc par
dérogation donc par une par une décision
que je prends qui peuvent être montées
jusqu'à 4 mois lorsqu'il y a eu un
historique de pénurie sur les deux
dernières années les deux dernières
années précédentes donc par exemple pour
l'amoxicilline qui est un médicament
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur il répond
pleinement la définition d'un MITM donc
l'amoxicilline orale c'est deux mois de
stock de sécurité donc la règle par
contre l'amoxicilline injectable c'est 4
mois c'était 4 mois parce qu'il y avait
eu des pénuries dans les deux ans les
deux années précédentes et donc ça ça
c'est un premier point et donc
concernant en effet ces stocks de
sécurité cela a permis de
[Musique]
l'impact et notamment puisqu'on a une
consommation qui a été multipliée
quasiment par 45 augmenter de 45% entre
l'automne 2021 et l'automne 2022 ça a
permis en effet de pouvoir amener on va
dire le déficit qu'il y avait mais ça ne
répond pas à tout le paracétamol n'est
pas un médicament d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur il n'est pas classé
comme imitem c'est une discussion en
effet que nous avons également avec les
industriels notamment sur la partie
pédiatrie voilà je en tout cas je pense
que l'on peut considérer que le
paracétamol pourrait remplir les
critères d'un ITM donc à ce stade le
paracétamol en effet n'est pas dans le
champ des stocks des sécurités quel que
soit sa forme injectable voie orale
adulte ou pédiatrique
le sujet des sanctions financières donc
en effet c'est un dispositif évidemment
qui est extrêmement important et qui a
été qui a été revisité revisité en effet
récemment et avec un élargissement de
l'assiette permettant à la NSM de
pouvoir prendre des décisions de
sanctions financière jusque et donc cela
est entré en vigueur en octobre au 1er
octobre 2022 donc il y a il y a quelques
mois en effet le périmètre au préalable
était limité il y avait peu de cas où
nous pouvions mobiliser des sanctions
financières et je partage le nombre
était particulièrement réduit pour
autant depuis le 1er octobre 2022 et
nous vous l'indiquerons en effet dans
notre dans notre dans nos réponses en
effet au questionnaire de la commission
cela a été considérablement en effet en
effet élargi en termes de périmètre
également aussi en termes de montant
donc nous avons publié en effet les une
directrice sur les sanctions financières
et
enfin j'espère
je n'espère pas qu'il y ait des
sanctions financières parce que quelque
part cela veut donc dire que voilà le
respect le respect voilà des obligations
n'est pas réalisée mais en tout cas il y
aura la possibilité de mobiliser de
manière beaucoup plus importante le
dispositif des sanctions financières à
titre d'exemple pour 2022 et notamment
plutôt sur le dernier semestre 2022 voir
le dernier le dernier trimestre 2022
nous sommes en cours de mobilisation de
trois sanctions financières eu égard à
ce dispositif en effet qui était élargi
depuis le 1er octobre 2022 il y a
évidemment des phases contradictoires à
réaliser avec les industriels ce qui est
tout à fait ce qui est tout à fait
logique il y a aussi des possibilités de
recours et les industriels peuvent se
mobiliser en effet deux possibilités de
recours soit de recours gracieux donc
auprès de donc par rapport à la décision
que j'ai prise mais également auprès
voilà du tribunal l'administratif et
voilà et cela sera probablement un jour
ou l'autre un jour ou l'autre le cas
donc un dispositif qui a été modifié
depuis octobre 2022 et dont l'objectif
est une mobilisation plus importante en
termes en termes de transparence parce
que c'est ce que vous indiquez je crois
madame madame la rapporteur tout est
public sur notre site y compris les
montants mais sur un temps voilà sur un
temps court qui est conforme à la loi
nous ne pouvons donc rendre public en
effet la décision de sanctions
financière avec le montant seulement un
mois et voilà c'est la réglementation et
voilà on ne peut pas le mettre au-delà
au-delà d'un mois voilà donc il faut
bien viser entre guillemets voilà pour
voilà pour avoir la formation mais on ne
peut pas assez des échanges que j'ai
notamment avec ma directrice
réglementation et déontologique alors le
sommier qui est ici présente et en effet
la loi et ce qui est aussi évidemment
normal
ça permet la publication uniquement
pendant un mois en effet sur le site
internet de la NSM mais lorsque sur
cette période tout est public et y
compris le montant en effet de la
sanction financière
concernant votre question sur la liste
en effet de médicaments critiques donc
dont l'annonce a été a été réalisé par
le ministre de la santé et de la
prévention à l'issue à l'issue en effet
du comité de pilotage
sur les pénuries donc
le début février
alors plusieurs éléments par rapport par
rapport à cela et par rapport à la liste
de l'OMS il existe en effet une liste de
médicaments essentiels donc de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
l'objectif de cette liste de médicaments
essentiels merci qui a été qui a été en
effet annoncé annoncé par par le
ministre permet
de pouvoir concaténer de de dimensions
la première dimension et c'est le
travail qui est réalisé
sous l'égide de la Direction générale de
la santé avec
auquel évidemment la NSM participe et
avec les sociétés savantes donc les
professionnels de santé pour définir
dans chacune desert thérapeutiques une
liste de médicaments en effet voilà
particulièrement essentielle et donc
particulièrement indispensable mais
également aussi tout le travail qui est
qui est réalisé donc à partir des
travaux notamment dans le cadre des
états des lieux que la ns dont la NSM
dispose de la part des industriels
chaque industriel chaque année doit
transmettre un état des lieux avec
l'ensemble des éléments par médicament
sur notamment la chaîne de production
les fabricants pour chacune chacun des
composants du médicament et donc grâce à
cette analyse et nous le faisons en
partenariat avec la Direction Générale
des Entreprises c'est dans le cadre des
suites de du rapport de 2021 qui a se
mobiliser que l'on appelle le rapport le
rapport Géorgie donc permettant
d'identifier des facteurs de
vulnérabilité par exemple un mono
fournisseur de substances actives ou un
mono fournisseur d'exception ou de
blister ou autre qui permettent
d'identifier en effet ces facteurs de
vulnérabilité ou on sait que s'ils si on
a un sujet sur en effet avec un mono
fournisseur par exemple de substances
actives et bien forcément il va y avoir
un sujet extrêmement complexe et donc
c'est la mise en évidence de ces
facteurs de vulnérabilité croisez à la
liste en effet des médicaments donc par
pathologie par chant thérapeutique par
er-thérapeutique identifié avec les
professionnels de santé va pouvoir
permettre de définir une liste en effet
de médicaments évidemment essentiel et
critique si jamais en effet il y a il y
a des difficultés enfin sur ce sur ce
produit eu égard en effet au
vulnérabilités qui ont été mises en
évidence et c'est dans ce cadre en effet
que sur la base sur la base de cette
liste de voir quelle mesure un peu on
peut mettre en place et on va y revenir
est-ce que c'est de la relocalisation
est-ce que c'est la diversification de
la production pour essayer en effet de
désulnérabiliser la chaîne de production
de ces médicaments juste pour illustrer
mon propos vous vous rappelez
probablement en effet c'était le temps
d'avant covid nous avons eu à faire face
à une pénurie de corticoïdes oraux
c'était en 2019 en effet avec une
situation très compliquée à nouveau là
nous sommes très gros consommateurs de
corticoïdes puisque plusieurs millions
de Français en effet chaque année et
c'est grâce à notre Groupement d'Intérêt
scientifiques épiphas sur la pharmacoé
épidémiaux a pu mettre en évidence une
consommation importante pour autant nous
avions une dizaine de spécialités
principes et médicaments génériques donc
lorsque l'on regarde en effet le
portefeuille on a l'impression d'être
possiblement sécurisé parce qu'on a une
dizaine de spécialités de corticoïdes
oraux pour en temps pour autant derrière
en fait et bien il y avait qu'un seul
façonn
en France d'ailleurs on n'était pas du
tout sur un sujet hors Union Européenne
ou dans des pays tiers mais donc avec
une difficulté en effet de de
fabrication de production et donc en
effet lorsque l'on a un seul façonnier
qui va évidemment alimenter l'ensemble
des spécialités et donc des différents
industriels on voit bien que le facteur
de vulnérabilité est majeur et donc
c'est tout le travail qui va être fait
dans cette liste de médicaments
critiques pour combiner les deux
approches pour
identifier en effet ces médicaments qui
sont considérés comme essentiels et qui
ont des facteurs de vulnérabilité sur
lequel il faut prendre en effet des
mesures pour désulnérabiliser la
production en effet de ces de ces
médicaments
et donc en effet l'articulation très
clairement la liste les listes en effet
qui sont mobilisés par les sociétés
savantes on aura évidemment un
recoupement avec la liste de l'OMS c'est
à dire que voilà même s'il y a des
spécificités d'usage et d'utilisation
enfin entre les différents pays on a
quand même de toute façon à on va dire
un
des éléments communs sur l'usage des
médicaments au niveau international
alors ensuite les solutions en effet
alors une fois alors une fois qu'on a
qu'on a les listes en Suisse donc ça ça
sera sous l'égide évidemment du
ministère de la santé et de la
prévention c'est en effet une fois qu'on
aura identifié ces éléments c'est quelle
mesure prendre pour des vulnérabiliser
est-ce que c'est aller vers un nouveau
site de production est-ce que c'est de
la relocalisation est-ce que voilà
est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'on a un sujet
pris voilà c'est très en deux au-delà
des missions de la NSM mais pour autant
en effet c'est pouvoir voir ce qui peut
être en place est-ce que c'est aussi et
on va peut-être en parler sur la sur la
dernière question de Madame la
rapporteur sur le sujet aussi
coopération notamment au niveau au
niveau au niveau européen donc cela fait
la transition en effet avec avec la
dernière question sur sur les solutions
voilà il y a comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il y a deux dimensions il y a la
dimension de gestion une fois qu'on a
l'intention une fois qu'on a en effet
les pénuries et comment on le gère
comment on le gère au mieux sur
l'information la traçabilité le partage
encore plus important des données avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la chaîne du
médicament que ce soit évidemment au
niveau industriel au niveau grossiste
répartiteur au niveau pharmacien
d'officine au niveau pharmacien
hospitalier et avec les professionnels
de santé et les patients mais anticiper
en effet les sujets et notamment sur le
sujet de de la de la relocalisation sur
le sujet de la relocalisation
et vous indiquez en effet possiblement
au niveau national je pense que un
premier point qui est très important et
on le voit au quotidien à la NSM c'est
essayer évidemment de s'écarter le plus
possible des situations de monopole et
de monocytes comme je l'indiquais
précédemment puisque cela enfin pour
nous c'est en effet la situation la plus
délicate lorsque l'on est sur une
substance active ou sur un médicament
qui est produit uniquement par un site
et y compris d'ailleurs au niveau au
niveau européen ou international j'ai en
tête des substances actives qui sont
fabriquées uniquement sur un seul site
pour l'entièreté de la population
mondiale en termes de substances actives
et donc quand on a un incident sur ce
type de substance est évidemment
extrêmement extrêmement compliqué donc
il y a le sujet en effet de de
diversifier donc essayer d'avoir des
solutions aussi possiblement de backup
donc à la fois en termes de sites de
production qui peuvent être activables
aussi rapidement on le voit et on le
voit les industriels aussi ont des des
recherches en effet de d'autres sources
de substances actives mais ensuite il
faut pouvoir le mobiliser c'est à dire
qu'il faut que ce soit en effet en effet
rapidement donc la relocalisation en
effet et la moindre dépendance par
rapport des pays tiers ou autres est un
sujet en effet qui voilà qui peut-être
une partie de la réponse je pense pas
uniquement je pense que la maille
européenne est quelque chose qui est
probablement important
je prends l'exemple des antibiotiques et
ce que l'on appelle les vieux
antibiotiques ou en effet
on voit qu'il peut y avoir au fur et à
mesure des arêtes commercialisation de
certains antibiotiques de certains vieux
antibiotiques qui concernent des niches
on va dire des populations extrêmement
restreintes et donc de ce fait
l'attractivité évidemment pour un
industriel n'est pas forcément évidente
à l'échelle en effet de la demande au
niveau national pour autant si on est
sur une maille européenne avec donc du
coup des besoins donc additionnés en
effet sur ces antibiotiques qui
concernent des niches cela peut
permettre en effet d'avoir aussi une une
attractivité probablement plus plus
importante et ne pas être dans une
situation où on voit sur certaines
gammes thérapeutiques et à nouveau je
repense aux anti-infectieux une
disparition des des antibiotiques en
effet anciens et qui est évidemment un
problème un problème un problème
important donc la relocalisation peut
être en effet une solution il faut bien
avoir en tête d'essayer d'être au
maximum enfin de s'éloigner du sujet du
monopole de monocytes parce que ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui qui peut qui
peut mettre en situation en situation de
délicatesse et puis vous l'avez aussi
annoncé vous l'avez énoncé pardon madame
la rapporteur la prise en compte de
l'ensemble des dimensions et de
l'ensemble des dimensions en effet à la
fois environnementale en termes de
production et donc c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui est qui est important
assez de la production c'est de la
chimie donc il y a évidemment tous les
enjeux les enjeux vous l'avez souligné
les enjeux environnementaux et donc cela
doit être pris en compte de manière
globale et évidemment les réflexions
aussi au niveau européen sur le sujet
sont importants puisque l'ensemble de
nos homologues sont confrontés aussi à
des situations qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement complexes
vous voulez compléter
oui juste par rapport à vous expliquer
et je vous en remercie on a été visité
au niveau de notre commission d'enquête
une pharmacie et là nous avons été
étonnés donc il produisait donc de
l'amoxicilline et nous avons été étonnés
par le fait que quand nous avons
interrogé le pharmacien qui a de pas du
Sénat il nous a dit qu'il ne souffrait
absolument pas de d'une pénurie de
principes actifs et nous a montré
effectivement que dans la salle où il
mettait
plus qu'en boîte mais enfin ou qui
s'occupait de de
faire les gélules il y avait pas il y
avait pas de souci il y avait des
cartons entiers de principes actifs
alors que nous on nous a dit
que à chaque fois il y avait une pénurie
des principes actifs et que c'est ça qui
expliquait un peu
la nature du problème et là on l'a vu
enfin c'est pas seulement on n'a pas
seulement écouté ce qu'il nous disait on
a pu constater réellement enfin tout ce
qui était avec moi là et toute seule que
ça n'était pas le cas alors voilà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire quelque chose
je suis tout à fait alors je confirme
les tensions sur l'amoxicilline ne
viennent pas de tension sur le principe
actif très clairement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons pu mettre en
place des préparations magistrales ce
que vous avez vu donc en effet les
gélules qui ont été ça devait être des
gélules de 125 j'imagine milligram
probablement aller à l'époque voilà la
recommandation que l'on a faite qui
permet en effet et ça permet ça permet
et ça permet encore aux parents d'ouvrir
la gélule de le mettre voilà soit dans
une compote ou quelque chose et c'est
beaucoup plus simple que d'essayer par
rapport à un comprimé de le couper etc
mais en effet sur la tension la pénurie
amoxicilline que
à laquelle nous avons à faire face
depuis plusieurs plusieurs semaines ce
n'est pas une tension de principe actif
c'est bien la fabrication donc la
fabrication de la suspension buvable ou
autre et comme je le disais
2020 et 2021 la consommation ayant
diminué de plus de 30%, les industriels
ont adapté leur outil de production en
effet par rapport à cette baisse et donc
la remobilisation pour des augmentations
de je relate juste factuellement je n'ai
pas de d'avis en effet voilà enfin je
m'exprime pas en tout cas dans ce cadre
là voilà sur sur cela mais en effet et
c'est la remobilisation en effet des
chaînes de production et notamment des
RH des ressources humaines parce que je
pense qu'en effet il y a une diminution
évidemment voilà de préparateur puisque
il y avait moins de consommation qui a
mis du temps mais en effet il n'y a pas
eu il n'y a pas de tension sur le
principe actif et je et dans cette
situation complexe et délétère que à
laquelle nous faisons face heureusement
qu'il n'y avait pas de tension de
principe actif parce que ça pu permettre
de mobiliser les préparations
magistrales parce que si nous si
l'origine était une pénurie en effet en
principe actif nous n'aurions même pas
pu enfin collectivement et surtout les
pharmaciens parce que c'est ceux qui ont
été évidemment mobilisés nous l'avons
fait donc on a à peu près 40 officines
sur le territoire national qui sont
autorisés à préparer des préparations
magistrales donc ça a été fait en
partenariat évidemment avec l'agence
avec les dictions de recommandations de
préparation puisque l'objectif c'est que
ce soit fait évidemment en termes de
qualité d'efficacité et de sécurité et
avec des volumes extrêmement importants
qui ont été mobilisés et qui ont permis
de répondre très clairement à la demande
et notamment pour les formes
pédiatriques puisque la difficulté c'est
pour ça que je parlais de la sensibilité
de la pédiatrie la difficulté était
vraiment sur les suspensions buvables
donc amoxicilline 125 mg ml et 250 sur
des petits pois ou en effet c'est
extrêmement compliqué on ne peut pas
évidemment donner un comprimé à un
enfant en bas âge ou aller couper enfin
voilà c'est quand même très compliqué
pour les parents ou pour les aidants on
a aussi le même sujet pour les patients
âgés les personnes âgées qui ont des
problèmes de déglutition qui ne peuvent
pas prendre de gélules ou de comprimés
et donc le fait d'avoir ces préparations
magistrales a été vraiment et voilà et
je salue tout le travail qui a été
réalisé par les pharmaciens a été
évidemment extrêmement extrêmement
précieux pour donner et pour voilà
donner des réponses en effet notamment
pour pour les jeunes pour les jeunes
enfants mais en effet c'est pas une
pénurie principale
je confirme très bien bien donc un
certain nombre de collègues Alain
houppert m'a demandé la parole
merci Madame la rapporteur Madame la
directrice de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament
je dirais que nous sommes en insécurité
en France et
propos m'inquiète parce que les
solutions que vous donnez sont des
pansements
il faut se poser les questions et les
bonnes questions
vous parlez de d'industriels de rupture
de chaîne auprès des industriels il y a
deux sortes d'industriels il y a des
industriels qui assemblent il y a les
industriels qui produisent et moi je
suis au sein depuis 2008 et en 2009 on a
eu la loi HPST j'ai voté contre c'est
toi c'était
majorité qu'il a proposé parce que
si tu n'as pas envie politique on a été
dans un cercle vicieux c'est à dire
favoriser
le générique pour diminuer les coûts
c'est un cercle vertu mais on est tombé
dans un cercle vicieux c'est à dire une
mondaine mondialisation malheureuse où
tout est fabriqué au diable vauvert ici
le diable vauvert c'est important parce
que à la place du petit Luxembourg il y
avait un château qui s'appelait Vauvert
et quand à Paris en disait allez au
diable vauvert voilà donc ici vous êtes
dans le diable vauvert pour qu'on vous
pose des questions et cette loi HPST a
créé
le système
pire que l'automobile parce que dans
l'automobile c'est pas le sous-traitant
qui commande alors que dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique cette sous-traitant qui
commande et on est dans un système de
flux tendu et on a la merci de deux pays
qui sont tout à fait respectables qui
sont la Chine et l'Inde mais je pense
que dans le médicament
le circuit court c'est pas mal vous
parlez de 40 officines qui sont capables
de faire des
productions magistrales mais nous avons
sans départements en France on se sente
mis en débutant c'est pas 40 officines
qui peuvent faire les choses et là moi
je crois en l'industrie je crois en
l'industrie qui est capable industrie
qui est capable justement de d'exercer
des contrôles de donner de la sécurité
aux médicaments alors si on va dans des
systèmes de système D excusez moi du
terme fait par des professionnels pour
compenser pour mettre des pansements sur
les insuffisances de la gestion de notre
sécurité alimentaire je trouve qu'on
marche sur la tête
il faut revenir comme vous l'avez dit à
une relocalisation et une localisation
urgente moi je me souviens du Clamoxyl
qui était fabriqué en France il y avait
pas de problème vous parlez de pénurie
de paracétamol et de et d'amoxicilline
moi je m'inquiète pas pour le
paracétamol parce que c'est le
gouvernement qu'on a fait la publicité
en disant n'allait pas chez votre
médecin n'allez pas me voir et surtout
prenez du paracétamol donc les gens ils
ont fait des stocks c'est sûr qu'il y a
une surconsommation et puis paracétamol
n'oublions pas que c'est quand même
quelque chose de toxique et je soigne
beaucoup de patients qui sont en attente
de greffe hépatique à cause de ce
médicament qui est soi-disant la panacée
non alors que bon les antibiotiques on
les prend de manière quand même un peu
plus pondérée quelques jours mais pas à
des jours et des années comme on est en
train de le faire actuellement et on est
en train de
faire du mal à notre population avec ses
médicaments qui se disant ne sont pas
agressifs mais qui sont agressifs à long
terme donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on revienne à des choses
intelligentes relocaliser la
mondialisation c'est pas quelque chose
c'est quelqu'un de libéral qui vous
parle
la mondialisation elle n'est pas
heureuse dans le cadre du médicament il
est important on a on a des industries
qui sont nous avions en France la
première industrie mondiale du
médicament maintenant on est loin
derrière les Indiens chers collègues
l'objectif c'est quand même de poser un
certain nombre de questions donc mais
ceux qui se questionnent clairement
c'est pour ça que je pose une question
qui est courte c'est très intéressant il
y a aucun souci mais essayons parce
qu'il y a d'autres collègues intervenir
et on a 25 minutes encore que
pouvons-nous faire madame pour
relocaliser d'urgence parce que le
Français attendent une relocalisation
d'urgence les médecins attendent une
relocalisation d'urgence et pas dans des
pharmacies dans des industries
il y a beaucoup de collègues qui veulent
prendre la parole après
donc on va on va faire question après
question peut-être et puis s'il y en a
trop on fera un tour de question merci
de
merci beaucoup merci pour merci pour
pour cette question juste un élément de
précision lorsque j'indiquais les 40
officines sur les préparations
magistrales bien évidemment ce n'est pas
une solution qui doit être
je dirais mobiliser de manière
régalienne mais on est bien dans la
situation on a une tension on a une
pénurie manifeste et il faut trouver des
mesures de réduction du risque pour
essayer de pallier à cette situation
pour autant bien évidemment la
préparation magistrale ou hospitalière
ne se mobilise que lorsqu'il y a déficit
d'approvisionnement sur les spécialités
venant des industriels et je partage
pleinement que on est bien sur ce schéma
avant tout les spécialités ce sont les
industriels qui sont responsables de la
garantie de l'approvisionnement et si il
n'y en a pas dans ces cas-là on mobilise
des mesures très clairement entre ça
enfin des préparations magistrales et
rien évidemment il vaut mieux avoir des
préparations magistrales mais ce n'est
pas l'objectif n'est pas d'étendre de
manière globale et préparation
magistrale sur le sujet de la
relocalisation je l'ai déjà indiqué
c'est un sujet évidemment un sujet un
sujet majeur et notamment
bien au-delà de la seule compétence de
la NSM et voilà c'est très
interministériel bien bien évidemment le
sujet typiquement pour le paracétamol
vous indiquez le paracétamol la
production de paracétamol notamment
adulte elle est sur notre territoire
national elle est très majoritairement
sur notre territoire national notamment
sur Lisieux mais sur un autre site donc
j'ai oublié Guillaume si tu peux voilà
bref mais dont j'ai oublié et à jeun
pour voilà pour un autre mais il y a un
autre site en effet mais un autre un
autre site aussi pour l'autre l'autre
industriel les les formulations
pédiatriques sont sur Cologne par contre
en Europe et donc le sujet de la
relocalisation il y a des projets sur le
paracétamol notamment
d'extension en effet de de la production
et donc voilà l'objectif c'est aussi le
plan France innovation santé 2030 de
leur relocalisation qui est portée par
par le par le gouvernement et je sais
que je crois que vous additionner le
directeur général de la Santé donc il y
aura des éléments évidemment beaucoup
plus précis que moi par rapport aux
champs de compétences de la DGS
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de la NSM pour qu'il
y ait en effet ces projets de
relocalisation en ce qui concerne les
missions de la NSA puisque comme vous le
savez nous avons un circuit du
médicament qui est particulièrement
sécurisé et notamment y compris enfin du
début de la chaîne jusqu'à la fin
avec l'existence de pharmaciens en effet
de pharmacien responsables à chaque
étape ce qui est évidemment un gage de
sécurité et de réassurance et donc nous
sommes mobilisés dans le cas s'il y a la
nécessité d'ouverture d'autorisation
d'établissements pharmaceutique
Guillaume Renaud le directeur de
l'inspection qui est qui est à mes côtés
la direction est fortement mobilisée en
effet lorsqu'il y a la nécessité
d'ouverture d'autorisation
d'établissements puisque évidemment pour
chaque industriel il y a la nécessité
d'une autorisation de la NSM pour ouvrir
toute ligne évidemment de production de
fabrication d'assemblages de
sous-traitance de grossistes répartiteur
donc l'agence voilà sera évidemment
mobilisée dans ce cadre là
merci Madame Paoli
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur Madame la Directrice Générale
merci pour cette présentation et ses
premières séries de questions
on approche basique on parle de notre
pénurie de médicaments donc ça veut dire
qu'on s'adresse quand même un marché ou
finalement la demande excès de l'offre
si je dézoome et que je me place sur un
strict point de vue macroéconomique je
pense un des premiers angles c'est de
s'attaquer à cette sur demande et assez
causes en fait est-ce que les causes
c'est pas un prix stable du médicament
et est-ce que un prix différencié du
médicament sur prescription et hors
prescription
ne nous permettrait pas déjà de
d'affaiblir un peu cette demande qui à
mon avis ne témoigne pas de la très
bonne santé de nos concitoyens ça c'est
le premier sujet et le deuxième sujet
est-il vrai on lit ça beaucoup et je
n'ai aucune idée sur la question n'étant
pas du tout expert dans ces matières
que sur certaines molécules en fait
on n'arrive même pas à challenger avec
le simple prix de la matière première en
fait on n'est pas compétitif par rapport
à un produit qui nous arrive
transformer packagié même pas ex-factory
Chine mais livré chez nous est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas merci beaucoup
merci allez-y merci beaucoup pour pour
cette question
à nouveau j'indique juste les le champ
de compétences de la NSM qui n'est pas
sur le sujet du prix et j'en suis j'en
suis désolé mais en tout cas je ne
pourrai pas forcément répondre à toutes
à toutes les questions en effet par
rapport à notre à notre notre champ de
mission et de compétences sur le sujet
offre offre et demande je partage votre
point c'est que on a un sujet évidemment
qui est important sur le bon usage et le
sur usage la surconsommation aussi le
médicament et ça c'est un point qui est
évidemment extrêmement extrêmement
important c'est le médicament donc pour
le bon patient à la bonne posologie et
le temps le plus court possible
évidemment et ça c'est un point qui est
important donc il y a tout cela sur le
sujet du prix même si ce n'est pas dans
le champ de compétences de la NSM les
prix sont différenciés entre les prix
d'un médicament remboursé et le prix
d'un médicament
non remboursé il est administré voilà
avec un d'accord
donc à nouveau ce n'est pas du voilà ce
n'est pas du champ de de
voilà de compétences de la NSM pour
autant les prix sont libres en effet
lorsque l'on est sur la prescription
médicale facultative donc non remboursé
donc voilà il n'est pas administré sur
le pour les produits qui ne sont pas
remboursés donc c'est voilà à la
discrétion voilà ou de l'industriel ou
voilà ou de ou du pharmacien en effet
notamment officinal donc ce n'est pas
réglementé seuls les médicaments
remboursés sont réglementés
et sur le sujet
primatière première prix produit packagé
cela après en effet notamment au prix
des médicaments des médicaments matures
ou en effet je pense que lorsque vous
aurez l'audition du président du comité
économique des produits de santé je
crois et du vice-président vous aurez
les éléments les éléments évidemment les
plus les plus adéquats possibles et donc
en effet voilà c'est ce qui est dit
notamment dans le discours public sur le
fait que il y a des prix pour les
médicaments génériques qui sont en effet
assez réduits est-ce que c'est le bon
prix est-ce que cela peut voilà prend en
compte l'ensemble en effet des des voilà
l'ensemble des segments notamment de ce
soit de la matière première que ça soit
du packaging ou ce soit en effet de
voilà de de la fabrication et à nouveau
dans le cadre du comité de pilotage sous
l'égide du ministre de la Santé de la
prévention et du ministre de l'Industrie
a été annoncée à moratoire sur la baisse
des médicaments génériques iques eu
égard à la situation donc c'est aussi un
des premiers éléments
Jean-Pierre Moga
merci pour l'exposé et les explications
que vous nous avez donné
moi je suis mon accent doit déjà vous
aider à repérer d'où je suis je suis du
Lot-et-Garonne et dans le Lot-et-Garonne
il y a eu ça
UPSA fabrique aussi l'efferalgan et
l'efferalgan je ne suis pas médecin ni
pharmacien mais c'est aussi du
paracétamol et il n'y a pas que Sanofi
qui fabrique du paracét non non mais je
le dis parce que donc quand il y a eu au
niveau surtout du des sirops et du
paracéthanol pédiatrique manque de
produits j'ai téléphoné à uxa c'est pas
loin de chez moi j'y suis allé et ils
m'ont expliqué que effectivement il y
avait un manque parce qu'il y avait eu
des problèmes et ils m'ont dit nous vous
savez on a doublé notre production
ils ont double ils travaillent jour et
nuit il travaille le dimanche ils ont
expliqué à le perce à leur personnel que
ils avaient un devoir
d'aider pour la sécurité du médicament
mais déjà on travaille la nuit le
dimanche et le sourire et tout mais il
m'ont expliqué aussi autre chose c'est
que eux ne fabriquent que 2 et demi pour
ça de ce qu'on consomme en France
c'était Sanofi qui faisait le reste
alors à votre niveau est-ce que vous
pouvez je défends pas spécialement il y
a les Laboratoires Fabres il y a
on veut réindustrialiser c'est très bien
mais déjà avec les labos qu'on a en
France est-ce qu'on pourrait pas imposer
à nos labos une répartition alors je dis
pas de dire à Sanofi vous passez à 20%
mais peut-être faire en sorte chez nous
à la campagne on dit qu'il faut pas
avoir les oeufs dans le même panier et
je crois que pour assurer la sécurité il
faut avoir plusieurs entreprises qui
soient en capacité de fournir quand
l'autre a des difficultés liées à des
pannes
je ne sais quoi et moi ma question
est-ce que à votre niveau vous ne
pourriez pas imposer une répartition
parce que ça nous fit ils ont rendu
service moi je viens de l'industrie
construire une chaîne on l'a construit
pas pour tourner pendant 9 mois pour nos
services aux autres on la met pas après
à l'arrêt il faut avoir un plan de
charge il faut que vous soyez capable de
garantir
au labo qu'on a déjà ici la possibilité
de de produire en moyenne et à long
terme de manière à mieux assurer notre
notre sécurité voilà ma question
merci peut-être qu'on peut prendre
l'ensemble des questions là parce que je
vois le temps qui qui tourne Laurence
Miller Brown merci Madame Alice
présidente bonjour madame moi je voulais
vous demander il y a eu donc un rapport
annuel de la Cour des comptes pour de
un rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes
pour l'année 2022 et donc il y a
différentes sur justement il y a un
chapitre qui est consacré à la sécurité
des approvisionnements des médicaments
et il y a donc différentes
recommandations dans ce rapport et des
critiques de la Cour des comptes bien
sûr et il y a certains éléments qui
concernent donc votre agence la NSM en
fait il est indiqué que le suivi des
déclarations à la NSM est insuffisant
pour appréhender l'évolution effective
des tensions d'approvisionnement puisque
seul une part très minoritaire des
déclarations qui vous parviennent entre
5 et 10% selon les années donne lieu à
l'inscription sur une liste officielle
médicaments qui de par les textes
entraîne l'interdiction pour les
grossisses répartiteurs de les exporter
en plus il est indiqué qu'il existe
plusieurs fichiers mais ils ne sont pas
agrégés donc tout le monde fait des
fichiers et finalement on n'arrive pas à
une solution il y a le fichier à NSM le
dossier pharmaceutique outil
informatique développé par le Conseil
national de l'Ordre des pharmaciens dans
les hôpitaux un outil de suivi appelé
edipostock et ces fichiers ne sont pas
rassemblés donc on n'a pas de vision
consolidée il n'est dès lors pas
possible d'objectiver l'importance et la
gravité des ruptures qui affectent la
population dans ce contexte là ni les
autorités sanitaires ni à fortiori les
usagers du système de soins ne disposent
d'informations satisfaisante sur l'état
des ruptures d'approvisionnement puisque
au début ne sont déclarés qu'une partie
minoritaire et puis qu'il n'y a rien de
consolider donc la question c'est
comment on peut vraiment lutter contre
les ruptures de médicaments si elles ne
sont pas correctement
identifiées et pourquoi on ne fusionne
pas d'abord toutes les remontées
d'informations
c'est une première question la seconde
serait
cette carence ou cette trop grande
demande de médicaments on a deux
éléments auxquels on pense en tant que
personne français lambda c'est l'arrêt
du remboursement de l'homéopathie donc
on peut se poser la question si ça pas
un report sur des médicaments comme les
voilà puisque beaucoup de gens se
traitaient quand même en homéopathie et
puis
la raie alors la carence des médicaments
matures où là on sait que les
laboratoires les brevets sont
au bout donc ça ne rapporte plus assez
pour les laboratoires de les produire
donc est-ce que je sais qu'au niveau
enfin on a entendu qu'au niveau européen
il pensait à
organiser un établissement public pour
racheter ces molécules qui aujourd'hui
ne sont plus intéressantes pour
l'élaboratoires et de pouvoir produire
du médicament avec ces molécules comment
vous dites comment vous les appelez
mature et qui sont maintenant hors
brevet merci
alors je vais me permettre d'ajouter une
question en prolongement de ce qui a été
qui vient d'être dit moi je veux dire
que quand on regarde vos slides que vous
nous avez montré au début on se rend
compte que la pénurie elle est partout
mais en même temps en France il y a un
système de
pronostic ou en tout cas de surveillance
qui est en train de se mettre en place
mais n'empêche que on n'a pas solutionné
la question de des pénuries même si
l'Union européenne voudrait en faire un
modèle européen donc est-ce que ça vient
du fait que le modèle est encore un peu
trop récent ou est-ce que il y a
d'autres explications donc ça c'est un
premier élément de question et la
deuxième question est en prolongement de
la précédente c'est-à-dire que les
pénuries c'est essentiellement dans le
cas de médicaments matures est-ce que on
peut envisager une production avec un
partenariat public privé ou une
production publique sur des médicaments
en effet qui sont d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur mais qui sont des
des médicaments matures pour reprendre
la maîtrise finalement de de cette de
cette filière là donc voilà et je vais
finir avec en donnant la parole à
Laurence Cohen qui avait encore des
questions qui sont qui sont venus avec
le débat bah oui après on vous donne
c'est dans le débat ça prolonge
effectivement les questions de mes
collègues très intéressants gestion de
Laurence Muller Braun notamment qui a
fait référence à la Cour des comptes
parce que je voudrais savoir si vous
avez pu répondre aux recommandations de
la Cour des comptes et si parce que ce
serait intéressant pour nous de savoir
s'il y a eu un espèce de dialogue en
fait c'est compliqué avec le grand écran
tu vois ça s'appelle un dialogue mais en
tout cas une réponse c'est une première
une première question après je pense
extrêmement intéressant de de pas
opposer
en tout cas pour par rapport de ne pas
opposer les médicaments
d'immatures et les médicaments innovants
pourquoi parce que effectivement sinon
on ne tient qu'un bout de la chaîne
c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir des
industriels qui vont pleurer parce que
c'est pas suffisamment rentable mais on
oublie que par ailleurs les médicaments
innovants sont plus que rentables
puisque ça atteint des sommes
astronomiques pharaoniques et que donc
on peut pas dire qu'il soit pertes donc
si on veut avoir une réflexion sur cet
aspect là je pense qu'il faut avoir la
globalité de la réflexion sinon ça sera
une fausse bonne idée en tout cas
j'aimerais avoir votre analyse là dessus
et la dernière question c'est que
certains fabricants n'avaient pas fait
part de la rupture de stock de certains
médicaments alors qu'il manquait
notamment chez les grossistes
répartiteurs en tout cas c'est
l'information que nous nous avons eu et
donc qu'est-ce que qu'elle peut être à
ce moment-là et bien le pouvoir de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament quand
vous avez vent de ce genre de
d'omission volontaire merci
merci merci beaucoup alors sur la
première la première série première
question en effet de cette de cette
série donc évidemment il y a plusieurs
fabricants de paracétamol et notamment
vous avez mentionné les deux les deux
industriels majoritaires qui au global
représente 80% de la production et de la
consommation de paracétamol en France il
y en a d'autres en effet donc des
laboratoires dit généricur mais seul
c'est deux industriels font notamment
des formulations pédiatriques et je
partage tout à fait ce que vous avez
indiqué donc c'est à la demande à ma
demande en effet que ce laboratoire a
augmenté à doubler en effet la
production notamment de forme de
solutions buvables pédiatriques pour
évidemment essayer de essayer de de
couvrir de couvrir les besoins sur la
question est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce
que la NSM peut obliger à ce qu'il y ait
des on faire des quotas voilà la réponse
est non je ne peux pas je ne peux pas en
effet je ne veux pas en effet obligé
ensuite évidemment c'est un marché
certes qui est régulé mais qui est qui
est libre et c'est chacun industriel
peut évidemment mettre mettre à
disposition il faut évidemment qu'il y
ait les commandes en face mais mettre à
disposition et c'est dans ce cadre-là
que nous avons sollicité
particulièrement l'industriel qui est
située à Agen pour mettre à disposition
des quantités supplémentaires et
notamment de formulations de formulation
pédiatrique
sur la question par rapport au rapport
en effet de la Cour des comptes et donc
oui nous avons eu des échanges
évidemment avec avec la cour la Cour des
comptes sur le sujet du petit
pourcentage de 5 à 10% qui aboutissent à
en effet une interdiction de déclaration
en effet une interdiction d'exportation
c'est ce que j'indiquais dans dans mes
propos au tout début de au tout début de
cette audition il y a en effet donc les
déclaration de donc de signalement donc
de risque de tension et de rupture et
l'interdiction d'exportation se fait
lorsqu'il y a le constat d'une tension
et d'une rupture effective qui permet la
mise à disposition sur le Site Internet
de l'agence en effet de la fiche rupture
de stock dans les 3500 signalements il
n'y a pas la publication évidemment des
3500 signalements puisque ce sont des
déclarations de la part des industriels
sur des risques potentiels qui sont
suivis en effet par l'agence et ensuite
lorsqu'on a bien la déclaration en effet
effective dans ce cadre-là il y a en
effet la publication sur les systèmes en
effet d'information il y a en effet
plusieurs systèmes d'informations et et
à la fois le système qui est donc de
déclaration que l'on appelle donc au
niveau de la NSM en effet donc où les
industriels déclarent les tensions les
risques de tension et les tensions avec
un certain nombre d'autres informations
utiles à la gestion on a en effet le
dépéruptures il dispostock qui n'est pas
un donc qui permet de recueillir les
stocks et les approvisionnements dans
les pharmacies hospitalières qui n'est
pas un système qui est mobilisé de
manière pérenne et je pense qu'il faut
avancer évidemment là-dessus pour avoir
évidemment la vision de ce qu'il y a
aussi dans les pharmacies hospitalières
ça a été mobilisé pendant covid ça a été
mobilisé sur certains cas où on nous
demandait la mobilisation mais pour
autant et c'est un travail qui est avec
le ministère de la Santé de la
prévention pour
institutionnaliser en effet que l'on est
cette vision en effet complète et donc
au niveau de la NSM nous avons nous
n'avons pas un système d'information
mono-boutons qui nous permet d'avoir
l'intégralité des éléments donc il y a
en effet plusieurs éléments et donc le
travail au quotidien des équipes c'est
bien de recueillir toutes les données
des industrielles les données en effet
les données que l'on a aussi au niveau
des grossistes répartiteurs les données
qui existent au niveau des officines et
je partage il y a il y a la nécessité
d'avoir avoir un système d'information
qui permette de faciliter le travail
aussi au quotidien de l'ensemble de mes
équipes on revient sur le sujet des
moyens des moyens humains des moyens
évidemment financiers qui sont
indispensables en effet pour avoir cette
vision globale et actualisée en
permanence cela est fait cela est fait
par mes équipes avec des fichiers et des
tableaux Excel croisés dynamiques mais
je ne dirais pas que ça marche pas parce
que pour autant aujourd'hui et on le
voit on a une consommation beaucoup plus
importante que ce soit de paracétamol et
d'amoxicilline mais c'est au prix en
effet de difficultés évidemment
importante et là avoir un système
d'information le plus concaténé possible
partager avec l'ensemble des acteurs et
en effet une une option qui permettrait
probablement de faciliter en tout cas la
gestion au quotidien
ensuite sur alors le sujet
homéopathie donc sur le par rapport par
rapport aux des remboursements je sais
que vous avez auditionné la présidente
de la Haute Autorité de santé qui est en
charge en effet du sujet du sujet
remboursement donc je ne sais pas ce qui
a pu être mobilisé
et moi on lui a posé la question elle a
dit que la France était le seul pays
avoir fait une étude donc elle a dit que
c'était pas un sujet politique mais
scientifique sauf que il n'y a qu'en
France qu'on a qu'on ne rembourse plus
l'homéopathie donc on peut imaginer que
c'est quand même politique mais elle a
dit qu'il y avait que la France qui
avait fait une étude sur les enfin la
France est formidable mais en attendant
les gens qui ne peuvent plus se soigner
à l'homéopathie vont se vont avoir
d'autres d'autres moyens de se soigner
bien sûr et puis il y avait les brevets
oui les médicaments hors brevet très
rapidement parce qu'on a les questions
d'actualité dans 5 minutes
malheureusement
voilà sur sur Oui production laboratoire
ça parce que je n'arrivais pas à me
relire désolé donc en bref donc oui
c'est ce que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
je pense que et notamment au niveau de
la maille européenne c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut probablement en effet
travailler sur ces médicaments anciens
ordrevés qui ne sont pas très attractifs
à nouveau les vieux antibiotiques avoir
une force de demande ou de production
alors à mon avis c'est peut-être plutôt
de demander et avec des partenariats en
effet possiblement public privé pour
avoir une force je dirais de frappe
suffisamment importante pour devenir
attractif avec ce que j'indiquais le
point majeur tout à l'heure c'est le
fait de ne pas être en monocytes en
monofabrication parce que là aussi c'est
évidemment un point un point important
mais sur ces produits très anciens en
effet qui peuvent concerner des petites
populations le fait d'avoir une demande
concaténée peut être peut être
importante typiquement là sur
amoxicilline enfin le sujet n'est pas il
n'y a pas de désengagement très
clairement des industriels sur la partie
amoxicilline c'est largement voilà
largement voilà largement largement
utilisée le sujet c'est l'adaptation par
rapport aux consommations fluctuantes
qui existent
sur le sujet du système de surveillance
c'est ce que j'indiquais le système est
en place permet d'être un amortisseur
mais ça ne répond pas à tout et
l'amortisseur il est uniquement dans le
cadre de gestion et de tension de
gestion des tensions et des pénuries il
y a tout le volet en effet anticipation
il y a tout ce que l'on a parlé sur la
relocalisation et sur le fait de
s'écarter du monocytes monofabrication
et puis le sujet du bon usage ça c'est
un point qui est évidemment majeur voilà
la consommation très importante est
évidemment un point un point extrêmement
important et puis le dernier point de
de Madame la rapporteur je partage
complètement le sujet le sujet en effet
de la du prix de la régulation des
produits de santé doit
se s'appréhender dans sa globalité je
partage complètement c'est un cycle de
vie on le sait les produits innovant
arrivent ensuite voilà ils sont utilisés
ils vont au bout de quelques années
perdre mauvais et donc on va être en
effet dans un dans des produits à
immatures et dans des produits ensuite
qui sont génériques et c'est bien le
cycle du vie qui va permettre de
réinjecter aussi pour la R&D et à
l'innovisage et l'innovation donc c'est
bien le cycle de vie en effet à la fois
de la chaîne de fabrication et de la
chaîne de valeur de l'industrie du
médicament et c'est dans ce cadre-là et
vous l'avez vu que la mission régulation
sur les produits de santé sous l'égide
de la première ministre a été mis en
place avec 5 personnes alités qualifiées
qui permet d'embrasser l'entièreté en
effet des dimensions à la fois produit
mature à la fois produit innovant mais
aussi le sujet qui
occupe votre commission enfin qui nous
occupe toutes et tous sur tension et
pénurie avec un seul objectif et si
juste le dernier mot c'est important
pour moi tout cela est évidemment avec
un objectif impératif d'assurer la
sécurité de nos patients et la sécurité
des patients c'est évidemment par
rapport au profil bénéfice risque des
médicaments mais aussi la garantie de la
couverture des besoins et ça c'est un
point évidemment qui est qui est majeur
avec la dimension de bon usage des
médicaments et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est qui est important
merci infiniment pour ces réponses je
vous rappelle que on est en attente de
la réponse écrite au questionnaire qui
vous a été adressé qui est assez
conséquent ce qu'on a parlé de 25
questions
je vais lever la séance et rappeler à
mes collègues que nous avons une
audition demain après-midi
qui est ouverte à tous bien sûr avec des
économistes du médicament et puis des
ensuite des magistrats de la Cour des
comptes on y a fait on y a fait
référence et on reprendra nos travaux le
28 février ensuite voilà merci
infiniment et bonne séance de questions
d'actualité